cleared of the new coronavirus these
blood donors are hoping to contribute to
a cure their plasma contains antibodies
that could help patients who are
seriously ill their identities have been
concealed to avoid them suffering any
stigma when they return to their
communities my blood may help more
patients in severe and the critical
conditions go home and reunite with
their families as I did China's military
has sent more supplies and medical staff
into Kuwait to help fight the outbreak
there are almost 12,000 critically sick
patients in the province alone in
addition to salary bonuses the
government has announced new incentives
for health workers the children of
frontline health workers will receive 10
extra points in key high school exams
younger children will be given
preferential access to public
kindergartens and those who died
fighting the outbreak will be given
national martyr status meaning their
family will receive allowances and
benefits after they pass away tough
measures have been imposed to protect
healthy tens of millions of people have
been restricted from leaving their homes
and have to rely on local teams to
deliver food the World Health
Organization says controls on movement
have helped to contain the outbreak
measure on movement restriction have
delayed the dissemination of the
outbreak of two or three days within
China and and a few weeks outside China
- three weeks so based on this then it
shows that those measure if well
implemented could have an impact on the
propagation of the outbreak restrictions
have brought much of China to a
standstill but some factories are
starting to resume production some
analysts say the outbreak will slow
China's growth by up to two percentage
points this quarter but it's still too
early to count the longer-term economic
cost of the coronavirus katrina you al
Jazeera Beijing let's go live now to
Adrian Brown who's in Hong Kong about
developments there and also on the
mainland where we're now hearing reports
of China expelling three Wall Street
Journal reporters Adan we've been
talking a lot about how the Chinese
government is trying
control this narrative is this a
crackdown well I think it's possibly a
warning shot to other Western news
organizations operating in China I can't
recall a time recently when so many
journalists from one organization have
been expelled from China they seem to be
paying the price for an article that
appeared on the opinion page of The Wall
Street Journal recently under the
headline China is the real sick man of
Asia well that I think was clearly a red
rag to a bull for the officials that
monitor the Western media in China and
as a result the Foreign Ministry on
Wednesday afternoon addressed
journalists and said that the article in
their view was racist and denigrated
China's efforts trying to contain the
virus now the phrase you know sick man
China the sick man of Asia references I
think a period in the late 19th and
early 20th century when China was often
referred to as the sick man of East Asia
this was a period when China was riven
by internal division at war and when it
was forced to sign a number of what it
saw as humiliating treaties like the one
that forced it to hand over Hong Kong to
Britain so it's a very sensitive subject
but we also have to see it in the
context of what happened 24 hours
earlier when the Trump administration
announced it was going to tighten
restrictions on five Chinese news
organizations operating in the United
States they now have to seek approval
when they want to buy property and also
submit the names of all their employees
to the State Department so I think we
have to see it possibly in that light as
well or very sensitive Adrienne I'm also
seeing that even as the number of new
infections in China is dropping
seemingly we're also hearing about more
deaths in Hong Kong yes we had one more
death in Hong Kong that was announced on
Wednesday this was a 70 year old man he
had an underlying condition reportedly
diabetes another man who died two weeks
ago also
had an underlying condition and that's
been a sort of common theme of the
deaths we've seen so far in Hong Kong
and also on the mainland the number of
deaths in the mainland though is
beginning to fall as is the rate of
infection now also in Hong Kong the
government has announced tonight
Wednesday that it's sending in an
aircraft to Japan to bring back more
than 50 Hong Kong citizens who've been
on that cruise liner the diamond
princess there are 350 Hong Kong
citizens in total on that liner 52 of
them have been confirmed to have the
virus but 200 others have been tested
negative but once they are brought back
to Hong Kong they're going to have to
undergo you know 14 days of quarantine
which means in total they would have
spent a month in quarantine including
the two weeks of course on board the
diamond princess it's a very long time
indeed Adrian Brown there in Hong Kong
for us thank you very much a dream